It is 12:13.
And we'll call this meeting to order of the— What day is it? I'm not
saying. It was noticed for yesterday.
It's, it's August 18th, as far as I'm concerned, at 12:13, and we'll
start our Redevelopment Agency board meeting.
And I'll officially call this meeting to order.
The first item of business is the minutes from June
16th regarding the Regulatory Development Agency board meeting.
Is there any questions on that one, or I'll take a motion if there's not.
Chair, I move that the board approves minutes.
Second. Okay, we have a motion
by Uh, board member Clark and a second by board
member Whiting, and we'll start the vote with board member
Huish. Yes. And board member Clark? Yes. And Wright?
Yes. Whiting? Yes. Wood? Yes. Okay, that passes. Now to
the first item resolution, and this is a public hearing resolution
of Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain City adopting the official project area
for the Mid-Valley Community Reinvestment Project area. It's the
exact same thing we just went through. Um,
any questions? Do we need anything
on this? If not, I'm open to a motion. Oh, no, no, no, I got
a public hearing. Sorry. Thank you. Um, at 12:15,
I will open the public hearing and ask Lacey.
Nobody wants to speak on that. Better not. Is anyone here that wants
to speak on this item? Seeing no one, uh,
we'll close the public hearing at 12:15,
bring it back to the council— or board.
Sorry, you're right.
Motion? Yeah. Chair, I, uh, I,
I move that the board approve a resolution of the Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain
City, Utah, adopting the official project area plan for the Mid-Valley Community Reinvestment
Project area. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Board Member Whiting, a second by Board Member
Clark, and we'll start the vote with Board Member Clark. Yes. Board Member Wright.
Yes. Board Member Whiting. Yep. Board Member Wood. Yeah. And Board Member
Hewish. Yes. Uh, 3B is also public hearing,
resolution of the Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain City adopting official project
area for the Mid-Valley Reinvestment Project area. Uh, it is a public
hearing. Do we need to answer any questions? Seeing none,
I will officially open the public hearing at 12:16. Ask Lacey
if there is anyone, and there is not. Is there anyone here that would like
to speak on this item? Seeing no one, I will close the public hearing at
12:16. Yes,
and bring it back to the council. Chair, I, uh,
moved— board, board chair, I, I moved that the board approve a resolution
of the Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain, City of Utah, adopting the official project area
budget. For the Mid Valley Community Reinvestment Project area.
2nd. Okay, we have a motion by Board Member Whiting, a 2nd by Board Member
Wright, and we'll start the vote with Board Member Wright. Yes. Board Member Whiting.
Yes. Board Member Wood. Yes. Board Member Hewish. Yes. And Board Member Clark.
Yes. Okay, the next one's item 4A, a resolution of
the Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain City approving the interlocal cooperation agreement
between Eagle Mountain and the agency and Eagle Mountain City for the collection and
remittance of an incremental sales tax. In the packet, this one's wrong.
This is the same as the other one. Sales tax is,
uh, it is not a public hearing.
So, if there are no questions, I remain open
for motions. Chair, I move that the board approve a resolution
of the Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, approving an interlocal cooperation
agreement between the Eagle Mountain Redevelopment Agency and Eagle Mountain City for the collection or
remittance of incremental sales tax collected from property within the Mid Valley
Community Reinvestment Project area. Okay,
we have a motion by board member Whiting, a second by board member Wright,
and we'll start the vote here with board member Whiting. Yes. Board member Wood.
No. Board member Hughes. Yes. Board member Clark.
Yes. Board member Wright. Yes. Okay, and I'm assuming the same thing, so we'll
move on to, uh, 4B, resolution of the Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain City,
Utah, approving the Mid-Valley CRA participation agreement between
the agency and the city. So, Not a public hearing.
Any questions? Any motions? Board chair,
I move that the board approve a resolution of the Redevelopment Agency of Eagle Mountain
City, Utah, approving the Mid-Valley CRA participation agreement between the Redevelopment
Agency of Eagle Mountain City, Eagle Mountain City, and Tara Smith's
Eagle Mountain LLC. Second. Okay, we have a
motion by board member Whiting, a second by board member Clark. We'll start with board
member Wood. No. Board member Hughes. Yes.
Board Member Clark? Yes. Board Member Wright? Yes. And Board Member
Whiting? Yes. Okay, that is 4-1. And, uh, motion to adjourn.
You win. Second.
Okay, so I've got Council— uh, Board Member Whiting and Board Member Clark.
Yep. And all in favor? Aye. Okay, thank you.
Appreciate you guys' work. I, I, um,
just— hey, hey. Just real
quick, and it might be too late. We had left some items on
the closed session. I think the consensus is that we're going
to punt. Is that okay?
Yes. I don't know if it was time sensitive. I don't
even see Abby. Abby's phone call. So I
think we need to talk about— We've already adjourned the meeting, so the ship's kind
of sailed. So if we need
to come back on that item. Yeah, we've already adjourned the meetings, so that ship's
kind of sailed anyway. Yeah, I don't know. That's my bad. So sorry, I should
have waited. I waited.